what's up everyone this is Anthony pop
Leon Oh most of you know me as pump
you're listening to off the chains
simply the best podcasting crypto let's
kick this thing off Brian s DS is a
Bitcoin og and the founder of off the
chain Capital a crypto fund focused on
finding value opportunities across the
industry now you got to give him respect
he found that off the chain name earlier
than I did so you know he has to be a
genius in this conversation Brian told a
number of awesome stories from the early
days of crypto he shared a few of their
investment strategies that have been
quite profitable and we had a great
conversation around the opportunities
that are likely to present themselves
over the coming years this episode was a
lot of fun to record and I hope you guys
enjoy it - all right guys bang bang I'm
here with Brian who's probably one of
the least known important people in
crypto I think is a fair way to say that
thank you so much for for coming to do
this yeah thank you for having me
for sure you live in a Chicago so right
now we're hours south of Chicago where
small town 10,000 people in southern
Illinois okay right outside of st. Louis
all right yeah my wife and I decided to
raise our kids in a small town so not
know what's the what's the reason for
that was a lot um my wife and I grew up
in a small town and we figured we turned
out all right we actually looked at you
know I got recruited by Goldman when I
was younger and we decided we didn't
want to raise the kids in a city so yeah
I just wanted to come to New York on a
day where it's 25 degrees outside so
you're you're a trooper for making this
happen but uh
cool man let's so let's start with kind
of early on in your life right so where
what what part of the country you grew
up in so my dad was Air Force I grew up
everywhere so we moved around a lot I
was born in Vacaville California at
Travis Air Force Base so live there ty
was six moved overseas we lived in the
Azores Islands where's that there
Islands off the coast of Portugal no so
live there for a couple years
logis Air Force Base is there was that
like it was it was actually great I
loved it so I remember going fishing
with my dad one day
and I caught a octopus like I was like
seven years old and I won't like rule on
this thing in and you know I started
crawling and like coming towards me and
my dad ran to the car and got a baseball
bat and killed it and then really yeah
and then we didn't know what to do with
it was it like a baby octopus yeah and
we didn't know what to do with it and
but our next-door neighbors were
Portuguese and we gave it to them and
they ate it for dinner that I know
totally freaked me out but I remember
Syd was sitting in like a five gallon
bucket of water you know and I kept
going looking at it and suppers yes it's
not exactly something that would happen
in southern Illinois no all right so you
guys are there and then where where do
you go after that then we moved to
Tennessee I was there for a few years
and then my day I got transferred to
Scott Air Force Base which is in
southern Illinois
Dennis Hill from sixth grade on I was a
high school yet in you know I'm southern
Illinois got it and then you've lived
most your life in a wheelchair right
yeah let's talk about how how that all
happened yeah so I was 16 years old I'm
six foot four when I was 16 you know 200
pounds you know good athlete well you
were six foot four at 6.6 before it when
I was in eighth grade actually Jesus was
14 early grower yeah you know and so I
yeah went to church that morning and
went to the mall with a couple of my
buddies and we were coming home on a
Sunday afternoon from the mall and hit a
pothole and popped the front tire on my
car put me into a skid into a telephone
pole and I ended up you know severing my
spinal cord from a you know you know
breaking my back basically yeah so you
know Brooke to Berta Brae my left leg
left arm punctured both my lungs
you know I was in the hospital for like
two months so so you're driving home you
told me before that it was on like a
country road right yeah yeah I was in a
Volkswagen bug so it's 70 1972 Beetle no
no seatbelts in there you know or they
have a VW Bug yeah so you know being a
big guy in a little car yes and can you
know it got crunched and when you know
it's doing 45 miles an hour so I was
that fast and yeah so that's got it it's
like what is that light you're 16 years
old right you're playing sports kind of
you know looking back at me at 16 you
basically think you're Superman right I
think every young athletic kid is like
I've yet to meet one who's not but then
all of a sudden you get this horrific
injury is it something where they're
like immediately hit you're paralyzed
and I right away I was paralyzed so I
right after the accident I was still in
the car and there were like legs up in
my face and I was pushing on the way and
I thought there are my friends legs
mm-hmm and I care because I got feeling
yeah you know I know it's like oh those
are my legs so I knew right away I was
paralyzed and your friend ended up being
okay he was fine yeah he was totally
fine cuz I took the pole on my side yep
so it's a you go I'm soon as much as
surgeries very exceptionally what is
that just mentally having gone from you
know the world at your feet to now it's
like hey look I've got to you know I've
got this long road ahead to actually
recover from this horrific injury yeah
so my dad said one thing that really you
know they actually said two things he
said the first thing was that you didn't
hit your head which is a blessing right
it's a good way to look at it yeah right
I forgot my brain and the other thing is
you know you play the cards that you're
dealt mm-hmm you know and that's how I
took my life you know this is what I was
dealt so I'll make the best of it it
really hasn't slowed me down yeah yeah
well and the part to me that is so
fascinating when you talk to folks who
have been to any kind of major obstacle
in life whether it's something that they
had to do from a mental perspective
something that they did from a business
perspective athletically right
physically whatever is a lot of times it
is the mindset right that completely
changes and when you're the you know
16-year old kind of pompous okay right
it's almost like the physical advantages
you have are good enough right and so
you don't have to have as sharp of a
mental you know kind of advantage and
you see this in some of the most elite
athletes in the world right you know
it's almost like they get more serious
and mentally change as they get older
because their body starts to fail that
right they can't jump as high run set
cetera but it's usually not as Extreme
as you know one day literally just a
point in time right you know the whole
mindset changes yeah so you know it's
like so I was in the hospital two months
y'all went from 200 pounds to 140 pounds
lost 60 pounds and then I got back to
the gym and started killing it again
yeah so I ended up being able to walk
with a walker with leg braces on I
actually walked up and got my diploma
what in the reg rated high school yeah
okay how long is that after the injury
so this is 200 years yeah yeah yeah so
and it's not really walking because I
can't move my legs
so my legs were basically I'm like
stabilized it yes stabilized and I was
just like walking like Frankenstein you
know she's like swinging my legs up yeah
it's like I didn't want to graduate in a
wheelchair you know I had somebody here
yesterday who he he recently told his
meniscus is not nearly as serious but he
spent the last 6 or 8 weeks with his leg
in a straight brace uh-huh and exact
maybe even though I blow my knee when I
was in college and do the same thing
yeah and you have to relearn how to use
your limb yeah right and you end up
walking around and if you're not careful
you can actually hurt other parts of
your body you ever compensating all
stuff yeah but it's pretty cool that you
know you say look I'm gonna I'm gonna
walk across the mat so I didn't the nine
it up you know wheelchair basketball
scholarship play basketball at
University of Illinois we got to talk
about that yeah what's going on
wheelchair basketball like I think there
was such a thing when I was in high
school you know yeah and I got a call
from because you know I was being
recruited by Michigan and Oklahoma to
play football and I got a call from
University of Illinois coach wheelchair
basketball coach and yes you know if I'd
like to play basketball and last time I
played competitive basketball was in
eighth grade
and when you were six for a we had a
seventh grader that was six seven really
yeah so we did all right they put in the
water over there I don't know so he was
Duncan eighth grade I did Duncan I got
technical foul
yeah yeah it was a rebound I didn't mmm
hung on the rim a little bit and yep
yeah I got kicked out of the game
actually I remember being in eighth
grade there was nobody dunking but we
would lower the rims god they're like
the retractable removable rims and we
used to put it down I think about a six
foot seven foot whatever it was and and
they would watch like the dunk contest
kids would you know through the legs
behind the back all this crazy stuff and
then we get the games and guys went
missing layups you're over here Duncan
agreed so as you go to play yeah we won
the national championship really four
years in a row
Wow no it wasn't because of me though
yeah I was in a very good wheelchair
basketball player so um but yeah it was
it was you know good to be competitive
again yeah I have no inside knowledge of
wheelchair basketball and you dribble or
you dribble you get two pushes on your
wheelchair and then you have to dribble
so it's traveling if you have three
pushes really yeah so that so basically
if I pass you the ball you might get
pushed ice and you have to dribble yeah
and how do you stop like I'm dribbling
right also yeah you're one hand oh god
yeah yeah you dribble with one hand and
but use your other hand to stop the
chair that's crazy
yeah and it's almost like you know like
smashed derby yeah well I actually run
into each other oh yeah and yeah like
you tip over and the huh legs are flying
everywhere and like it's kind of it's a
little why that's five on five that's
why I went full court yeah full court
yeah that's crazy
alright so you do that and then you
graduate I'll graduate yeah one of the
other things too when I was at
University of Illinois is that I was
asked to go to Cambridge University to
represent the University for the
economics program okay so I studied at
Cambridge and London School of Economics
as an undergrad was also there it was
great I mean I me and Stephen Hawking
and were lying to guys in wheelchairs at
Cambridge so it was a very accessible
and yeah it was it was hard to get
around but it was worth it yeah
worth the sacrifice to did to do that
yes any like one or two memories from
there that you're just like that this is
like really yeah actually it held up
what it was like yeah it's so Sir Isaac
Newton actually was a professor at
Cambridge and so one of the lessons that
we learned when classes that we took us
about the history of stock market
bubbles and history of bubbles because
he lost all his money in the South Seas
bubble died penniless and that's one of
the lessons that we learned there so we
learned about s curves and stock market
bubbles and you know the history of all
that so that's pretty and that's one
thing I've used throughout my career as
an investor yeah so all right so you go
you got a university illinois' then go
Cambridge come back to Illinois come
back my graduate and bachelor's degree
we walk across the hold across all
rights to get the degree then at 22
yeah got to go out into the into the
world man yeah first job was that
McDonnell Douglas okay I'm you know you
know it was just like making twenty
three thousand dollars a year pricing
out contracts with a Harrier jet and
this is 1990 go for started there was a
recession end up getting laid off
because McDonnell Douglas was cutting
back and I always wanted to be a
stockbroker so I called around and I got
an interview or Shearson Lehman Brothers
and they've never heard of them yeah I
saw I ended up getting hired there go
through their new broker training
program this is late 1990 and really
excited do that and then the Gulf War
started in 91 January 91 and they
cancelled the training program really as
I was out there too and so but the
branch manager Shearson used to own a
brokerage firm with Geiger in Ag Edwards
and Sons in st. Louis so he referred me
over there and I went to go talk to
Charlie and so I'm 22 I go into the
interview you're 22
you're 22 at 16 year in a wheelchair
yeah I went for national championships
in college and then in the span ova
sounds like a couple of months you lose
two jobs so I go talk to Charlie and I'm
going in the area and we said
and he goes how old are you and like 22
and he goes I don't have very good luck
with 22 year olds and he just shut up
like he didn't say another word for an
hour and so I started talking and going
through my business plan and how you
know I was I'm bringing clients AG other
words and built my business and I just
kept talking and talking if I he told me
just shut up yeah and then he said you
know why don't you go down to the Home
Office take a test interview with our
vice chairman and Donna's Casey and you
know see where that goes
so I went down there interviewed with
her and she asked me doing the
interviews really weird she goes pick
something out in this room and sell it
to me and as I'm speaking to myself like
what does this have to do with being a
stockbroker because I thought being a
stockbroker was like managing money for
people right but it was a sales job you
know and and that's when I first learned
that being a stockbroker was a sales job
yeah would you think you remember it was
a pencil
yeah yeah it was not hitch the pitch was
that it was a brand-new number-two
pencil with a you know red eraser on it
never been used you know shiny yellow
coat of that pencil in the world yeah
she was happy with that yeah all right
so you know getting the job job and and
kind of what was that experience like
and I know you've learned a lot of
lessons there and stuff so maybe I share
some of those as well yeah so as a new
broker you know we were you know you got
this opportunity to be broker of the day
and when your broker of the day you
taken the walk-in clients or people that
call in so this is you want to be broker
at the day the older guys didn't but
when you're a new guy with no clients
yeah you want to be Roker everyone
everybody every day yeah and so at this
elderly lady come in and she was in her
late 70s name was mrs. Smith at red yeah
and she ended up being one of my best
clients and she came in she said she
came from her lawyer's office and they
just set up a trust for her and she was
a widow and she wanted to get everything
rear edge' stirred into the trust name
so that when she passed away her
beneficiaries could you know have easy
access to the money and she asked me to
go to the bank with her and clear out
her safe-deposit box and I thought it
was kind of weird but I was like yeah
I'll go do that
so we over to Bowman's bank and helping
her clear out her safe deposit box and
get back to the branch and we're looking
in the securities with the cashier and I
noticed that she had a lot of Walmart
certificates in there and and the way
the systems worked back then you got to
wait till the next day till everything
matched to see how much she actually had
so I asked her to come back the next day
and we'll meet and review everything so
she comes back and we pull up the
account and she had like almost 2
million dollars with a Walmart stock and
in addition to other things this is in
1991 1991 yeah Wow and I asked her to
tell me the story like you know how did
you get involved with Walmart and she
said her sister in 1974 went to work for
Walmart and she said it was a good
company and so she ended up investing
eleven thousand dollars in Walmart and
it kind of hit me like well you invested
eleven thousand and seventeen years
later in 1991 is worth almost two
million and after she left the office I
pulled up a value line report just to
kind of see what Walmart did over that
period and I noticed on the chart that
there were four periods where Walmart
dropped 50% or more during that 17-year
period so there were four times where
she lost half of her money but since she
was collecting the stock certificates
and putting them in her safe deposit box
she wasn't you know she wasn't checking
the price every day she wasn't actually
getting brokerage statements yeah
because everything was in her safe
deposit box so there were probably times
where she lost like it went from a
million dollars to a half a million
dollars and she didn't know and she
didn't care and and that's really where
it hit me that you had to be a
successful investor you have to focus on
the long term yeah you can't let daily
price fluctuations and no movements in
it so you have to you know what time
smooth out the volatility yeah because
everything is volatile but if you add
enough time to it it smoothes all that
out and I think successful investors you
know could apply that you know that
lesson yeah well it's a bit coin and
crypto yeah and we're talking beforehand
like another data point here is we think
it's fidelity we can all doable with
Josh Brown from
tolt came over he came on the podcast he
said there was a study done that suppose
he's been scrubbed from the internet and
that study was they looked at all their
clients said who had the best performing
portfolios over long periods of time and
they measured it you know by
appreciation of value etc and the two
that had the best performance for people
who lost their passwords were had died
right right that's exactly right so it's
this idea that like actually if you pay
attention to the headlines you will suck
some come to fear and greed and human
rights right yeah it is a motion it is
why psychological you know analysis of
markets is so accurate and I think that
what we're seeing one is obviously a
very rapid rise of the machines trading
right right they don't have those those
human emotions but also to is no matter
what the asset class does no matter what
the market is like there's some core
kind of best practice it's not even
wolves bears best practices that help
people navigate these markets and that's
one of them right right it's like look
having very very long time horizons is
super helpful when you're investing in
the right thing right right yeah how do
you think how that compares today -
Krypto so I see it all the time you know
people getting of it like 3:00 in the
morning to check their coin cap you know
just like yeah yeah I do the same thing
you know but I have enough discipline
now over 30 years to just let it go you
know you know and I I've traded myself
probably out a half of my Bitcoin over
the past six years really yeah yeah even
though I know that lesson
yeah but I'm to the point now I'm not
selling anymore you know yeah so yeah
and so what are the lessons did you
learn when you're kind of a you know
young twenty stockbroker and and I'm
sure that there's all kinds of fashion I
think yeah so another one was so I
really didn't know what I was doing
right when you're 22 you know so you
think you do you think yeah I I do I did
it so I went to talk to Leo who is the
oldest broker in the office okay so he
was almost 80 years old been in the
business for 60 years
same company AG editor was started in
1887 so you didn't start way back then
but Wow that's probably you know
19:40 is a runner when he started 60s
you gotta respect somebody who's 80 and
still shown up to the office he worked
their togas 105 yeah he died at the
office
really yeah yeah I must have loved it
yeah he loved it the one that I guess
that's an 85 years yeah right
damn all right so you've been [ __ ] I
go talk to Leone's like Leo I'm new my
first week here can you tell me you know
you've been here for 60 years and he
didn't say anything he slid a piece of
paper across the desk to me and I looked
at it and it was a value line report on
Berkshire Hathaway and he goes just put
all your clients in this and I looked at
it was four thousand five hundred
dollars a share four thousand five
hundred dollars a share in 1981
Berkshire Hathaway and I was like I was
like you're crazy like no one's I buy a
four thousand dollar stock you know like
who buy because I didn't know the
difference between price and value yep I
don't know how to value a company you
know I just saw the price you know the
price was four thousand five hundred and
today Berkshire Hathaway's what three
hundred and forty thousand or something
crazy you know thirty years later and
and that's you know one of the lessons I
learned too is that you have to know the
difference between price and value you
know like people today look at Bitcoin
and they look at the price at eight
thousand they don't know what the value
is what's the value of Bitcoin
and that's where you have to figure out
you have the value is something more
than eight thousand you want to buy it
if it's something less and probably want
to sell it yeah and I guess really part
of that is not only one a lesson on
Berkshire Hathaway right but also just
more systematically at the pricing value
did you learn that by asking questions
to him did you kind of know I never want
any Berkshire Hathaway no I'm not buying
a 4,000 did you end up learning the
different price about it just over time
yeah over time you know being in the
business for you know 20 years of the
institutional equity broker and you know
you just kind of figure it out you know
and looking back over my life you know
when I should have bought Berkshire
Hathaway at 4,500 you know yeah
hindsight's 2010 and I think the people
are I feel the same way 30 years from
now when they look at Bitcoin
I think 30 years from now Peter why me I
should have bought it eight thousand
mm-hmm you know and it's whatever it is
in the future of course what um what was
the first time you ever heard about
Bitcoin or crypto so 2013 was a you know
investment manager managing 350 million
dollars for a small number of endowments
and foundations in st. Louis area had a
nice easy life you know raising the kids
on like you know and saw Tyler and
Cameron Winklevoss on CNBC talking about
it at the time it was a hundred dollars
and you know I didn't know anything
about Bitcoin I just kind of I thought
it was kind of a scam or yeah yeah I
thought these guys are doing a pump and
dump you know talk about Bitcoin on CNBC
you know they own 1% they're trying to
pump up the price and so I kind of put
on my watch list because I'm a value
investor
and so I watched it go from 100 and then
Congress held hearings in 2013 and that
pumped up the price to like 400 and then
IRS came out with guidance and called it
a call to property and that's how
they're in tax it and then a shot up to
like 800 and then got it to 1,200 the
mount GOx got hacked and then it crashed
down to 300 and that's when I kind of
took a dive into it well I figure out
I'm a value investor I figured the
suckers were washed out if it was at
1200 it's at 300 today there's probably
some value opportunity there and I
wanted to figure out where the
opportunity was would you do to go
figure that out I read those Toshi
Nakamoto white paper I mean that's nice
to start I go what is Bitcoin and that
was one of the things that popped up and
as soon as I read that it like clicked
like when I was in high school I used to
code and like Fortran and Pascal and
COBOL and all those ancient languages
and you know I say there's some young
kid listening right now like what the
hell is it talking about I had this you
know kind of like computer science
background when I was in high school and
then I had a financial background you
know being a stockbroker and it kind of
all came together and when I read that
and I saw his clear as day how we
rebuild the financial system that we
have today on blockchain technology and
I told my wife I was like
I need to get involved with us and
they're kind of weird but you know I
couldn't sleep for like a week
yeah I'd lay in bed and she could feel
the heat radiating out of my body
and she would yell at me like like just
go to sleep you know yeah I can't and so
so I told her you know I want to do this
and I go the best way I think is become
a VC like a mentor capitalist in the
space and help build and she was like
what's a VC I was like I don't know
that's what everyone else does when they
want to build things and so I kind of
tried to figure out what a venture
capitalist is and she goes how much does
that pay and I was like I don't think it
pays anything I think we're like writing
checks all day the other way the money's
going out so she was kind of nervous
about that and she wrote down on a piece
of paper and you know a number and she
goes put this in the check-in account
and go do what you want and so that's
what I did
that's a pretty good partner in that
yeah so we've been dating since high
school
uh-huh so yeah it's yeah she's been a
you know great wife so yeah he's seven
years now I've been married Wow yeah and
so I put that in the checking account
sold my practice to Wells Fargo and
became a VC and blockchain and just kind
of like and I didn't know what what to
do it later and I felt like a new broker
again yeah right so would you do when
when you're like okay [ __ ] I'm here so
this probably sounds kind of desperate
but I went in to like go meet VC's right
and figure out like how to do it and so
I called some up and they want meet with
me and so I know I'd looked on charity
buzz you ever heard of charity but no
what's that because charity buzz is a
website where people donate items or
meetings and then you buy them and that
money goes to their favorite charity
okay that's a great idea
yeah so I when I was looking through
charity but as I noticed there were a
lot of VCs offering meetings ah yeah so
I spent about $10,000 on charity buzz to
get like six or seven meetings with VCS
so I met with some great VC's yeah first
of all I don't I don't don't say names
but I wonder who's on there right but if
people by going to look they know who
they
yeah and two is how do you set your
price for something like that it's an
auction it's an auction it's like most
auction oh yeah yeah yeah so they don't
get to set the prices well no yeah yeah
it's it's an auction format okay so yeah
alright sorry but when you meet with
them it was that conversation like do
they take it seriously or are they like
oh this is raising money for charity and
so they just like want to screw around
no yes yeah no it's you know very good
meetings mm-hmm yeah so what you learn
from them so I learned what a VC did you
know like you know how to get involved
and depending who you ask
yeah I know I have bad definitions yeah
so some weren't very good VCS and you
know they told me their life stories and
some um or you know the top feces in the
nation and you know I learned a lot from
that and one of the things I learned I
was beaten with when the VC is at 8:16 Z
in Greece in Horowitz and you know we
were talking and I wanted to get into
coinbase and I knew they just did the
seed round and the a round and I asked
her like can you get me into coinbase
you know and she's like well why do you
want to buy coinbase when you go buy
Bitcoin and it's like well because it's
a company and being from a traditional
finance background I thought the best
way to you know make investments to do
companies and she goes now I know you're
all wrong she goes all the partners at
8:16 Z in Driessen you know we're buying
Bitcoin you know coinbase we have to buy
coinbase because that's were mandated
build equity in companies but she told
me the partners were you know investing
Bitcoin directly and I thought she was
trying to make me feel better
you know cuz I couldn't get in and so
eventually I would go my way into the B
round at coinbase and but yeah looking
back I mean she was right
yeah Bitcoin did a lot better than
coinbase yeah well her base is done
great well I think but I think that from
the series a probably but I think the
seed round coin base has appreciated
more or no so I got into the it's either
the B or the C right they went from A to
C around okay but I guess that's the B
round yeah it didn't like to see yeah so
it was a four hundred and eighty million
dollar valuation and when I got
yeah and so today we're sitting at just
under $8,000 Bitcoin or so yeah so and
Bitcoin was for centuries yeah
when so Bitcoin went from 400 to 8,000
and coinbase went from $16 to it's about
$200 today got it so but so Bitcoin did
better yeah yeah yeah got it and so you
make the initial investment in coin base
and you've continued to do you know a
bunch of stuff with them kind of how did
you think about that company and why
were you so bullish on kind of what
their prospects were it reminded me of
AG Edwards and Sons so it's a brokerage
model you know they're making you know
at the time those one percent
Commission's on buying and selling you
know and that's how we made money at AG
Edwards yeah we charge commissions to
buy and sell things
mm-hm so it seemed like a natural model
so and as I dope deeper into coin base
when you're a broker
it's either the agency model or
principle model and I couldn't ever get
the answer from quite a visit I think
they're doing both yeah explain the
difference for this all right so on a
agency model you're making a commission
you're being the agent for the client
okay so you charge a commission on a
principle bottle you're making money in
the spread so if a stock sells for 16
and this is back in the olden days when
Sox trade for 8th and 16th if there was
a spread of six and a half cents or
twelve cents then you would make that
spread the difference between the bid
yeah yeah so basically I'm willing to
buy it at $13 you're willing to sell it
at you know thirteen fifty or whatever
whatever basically we both execute the
transaction and we're happy because
that's what we were going to do but that
difference between the bid and the ask
$0.50 different the broker makes a
brokerage firm makes yeah and I was an
institutional equity broker for you know
14 years and that's how we made money we
made the money on the between the bid
and the ask and so when I looked deeper
in the coin base not only were they
making them 1% but in that like I said I
can never get the answer but it looked
like they were making money on the
spread too and that's a great model
weird double dipping like that yeah yeah
got it okay so you did coin base and
then what else did you see out there
that you got excited about so I tried
investing in
1ko so I think because enduro it's yeah
Balaji and so actually talk to Balaji he
said there was about a half a million
dollars worth a stock left that injury
sin didn't take and he asked me if I
wanted it I was like sure yeah I'd love
that and he took it to their board and
they said no they're like who's Brian we
don't know him you know and so I got
shut out of that which turned out to be
you know nice and because they ended up
getting bought out by coinbase
and so I actually looked at digital
currency group because I knew Barry from
SecondMarket I used to buy Facebook
stock through him when it was a private
company and so I knew he started this
you know digital currency group which
was involved in crypto and I found one
of the co-founders who needed money for
private schools for his kids and he was
willing to sell me some DCG so I bought
some
you know DCG stock from him so this is
an important thing right a lot of people
I think definitely under credit
investors don't know this world exists
and then even accredited investors that
most part don't know that this world
exists where basically you can invest in
the fundraising rounds so hey the
companies raising X dollars at Y
valuation and here so they're going to
do it the capital bunch of people look
at the deal some do it some don't and
everyone kind of thinks of those
attritional fundraising round either
alongside those rounds or in between
those rounds there are employees
founders sometimes even investors etc
that want liquidity but there's no
public market to go sell them into
there's no acquisition or anything like
that
those secondary market transactions can
one be super valuable right because it
helps them get that liquidity that they
need whether it's for hey we've got to
liquidate our fund or I want to put my
kids in private school or I just want to
go buy my house right you know whatever
it is yeah get married whatever it is
there's that but also there's the
ability for folks like you if you're
sitting there and you're like hey I want
equity in this business but there's no
ability to do that oh I found somebody
who has some that wants to sell it to me
and then you can kind of facilitate
those secondary transactions it sounds
like you've done that quite a bit
whether it was with things I gotta find
ways to like I got you know I was told
no on the be round in coin base and
this sounds desperate I know I guess
there's no desperation yeah that's what
I wonder I get in yeah so so so I
started contacting like cold calling and
you know DM and coinbase employees yeah
I know you know so what was their
response I was so I ended up getting in
touch with her name is Kristen new
employee at coinbase and she gave me a
call and you know she's new so she had
me stock and I told her you know just
let me know if you hear of anyone I'd
appreciate it
next day I get an email from Olaf and so
you know he put me in touch
Olaf was the first employee the first
employee calm voice and so Allah put me
in touch with people that we're looking
to sell and that's how I got in so I
mean it's fine from a group of employees
at coin but yeah but but it speaks to
covet persistence right it's like hey
look you go knock on the front door and
they say no right then you kind of knock
a second time no yeah right all right
well look I'm either gonna kick the door
in the back door so you know getting in
the house and I was even thinking about
I should just go work for him because I
wanted equity so much I was willing to
you know if I can't buy it as I go out
there and work yeah and so you and Olaf
that wasn't the only time you guys hung
out no no we became friends yeah yeah it
so kind of talked a little bit about
kind of your guys relationship moving
forward yeah so it moved forward so he
ended up certain poly chain capital and
I had the opportunity to be a general
partner there and you know help build
that and you know and it's just you know
it's been a great relationship and what
was the thought process behind starting
poly chain so when he told me the idea I
told him you know it was the best idea
I've ever heard in my life
I've looked at thousands of business
models over my lifetime as a
professional investor and this one's the
best one I've ever and it's still the
best a cryptocurrency hedge fund
building in the space with you know with
the macro view looking out in the next
30 years if you could do it like Olaf's
doing it which is you know the best way
of doing it where you focus on the
long-term and you're you're building
this new technology and helping develop
it early-stage you know that's the best
way to help the ecosystem mm-hmm and so
I'm just blessed to be a part of that
you know as a general partner and you
know and I was also the first check-in
the fund has a limited partner yeah and
so the thought process there being it's
a macro bet on an industry that the
Webster architecture right super small
today we end up being really big in the
future yeah and I don't have the
technical skills anymore to do that so
when I'm out you know meeting with the
team out there I feel like an idiot you
know you know I I have the experience
with the financial background and all
that you know but yeah I mean those guys
are super smart yeah I mean you know
it's yeah they really know what they're
doing and you know I'm proud of them
yeah for sure
and then you guys have done a lot of
other stuff right so you ended up buying
Bitcoin at standpoint right and tell a
little bit about you are one of the few
that's sold in December of seventeen how
what was kind of the the the reason for
doing yeah so we had like two pots of
bitcoins so one is my personal time so I
started buying that at like four hundred
it went up to 650 and then you know went
down to 178 you know say at one point I
was down 60% on my investment and this
is when it was really early right and
you know I was like you know I'm either
early or I'm wrong and so I doubled down
on my for the same thing right yeah
right so I double down on my research
and I figured I was early so I ended up
you know buying more and and then at the
same time 2016 I had friends and family
who wanted to get involved and we
figured we would start this fund for
them called off the chain capital it's
great name yeah so we started off the
chain capital in 2016 just a lot of
friends and family to come in so yeah we
got talking right where'd you get the
name from my wife came up with it no way
yeah she's the hip hopper and the family
okay all right so this I'm the nerd this
is my big this is my big I'm shocked at
how many people don't get the double
entendre I'm off the chain
yeah so I didn't get it either these yet
exchange right now and instead like
there's all these crypto businesses that
have the word chain or whatever in the
name block right over and stuff but as a
kid we used to always say like oh that's
off the chain yeah right and it was like
a cattle kid you tell you use all kinds
of words and open you know but that was
just a phrase that right yes and so the
first time that I go off the chain like
that's off the chain you know the whole
double meaning yeah I remember being
like this is gonna be so obvious to
people uh-huh
nobody ever says anything about it and I
don't know if they're all coming it from
so crypto specific yeah right but like
my friends are like dude are you kidding
me you start us on the car off the chain
yeah but they're not think about crypto
think about it in terms of the same so
the fact that she came out that makes me
like her already yeah so she came up and
like I said she had to explain it to me
what it meant because I had never heard
him off the chain before a social
neophyte so I kind of live in my little
hole yeah so anyways so we started off
the chain capital put about half a
million dollars from friends and family
it you know spiked up to like ten
million dollars and December 2017 and I
was getting nervous cuz you know I was
hearing Bitcoin advertised on the radio
and a lot of people were talking about
it but what the key was that I was at
Bitcoin meet up and this Elbert elder
lady lady came up to me she was late 70s
probably and she wanted to buy some
Bitcoin and she was talk to me about how
to get involved with Bitcoin and I was
like yeah you know it's probably not the
right time you know it's kind of high
right now and she goes well I want to
sell my GE stock and buy Bitcoin and at
the time GE was at an all-time low and
being a value investor I knew that was
the wrong move for her you know I was
like well I'll you know sell you some of
my Bitcoin for your GE just kind of
joking not that we you know did that but
yeah but when I got home that night I
was like you know it's it's the wrong
time right now you know older you know
investors are wanting to sell their GE
stock which is the all-time low to buy
Bitcoin was the all-time high you know
that's just emotion getting involved
well it goes back to your story about
Walmart right yeah is somebody knows
what the price
Yii stock is and you know they're
willing to get rid of it right kind of
the feeling can take the pain anymore GE
right yeah yeah okay and so you go home
you go home and yeah yeah I thought
about it for a few days and I decided
and you know it's best just though let's
look what he had the portfolio and so we
sold 80% of the assets return the monies
to the LPS and and then the shell of
quite pretty happy yeah they're all
happy yeah so and we gave them the
choice either taking cash or taking the
crypto 1/2 um took the cash half um took
the crypto really so we just yes you
know it said I'd sent the crypto out to
UM and then they wrote it down like I
rode mind I that's how my personal
mmm-hmm you know Bitcoin you know I'm
you know I just wrote it up wrote it
down it's um it's funny because the
longer that people are around the
stronger the hands get they are yeah
right I just saw the stat in 2018 era
it's just a 19 I think it was at the end
10 million Bitcoin haven't moved in a
year I saw that too right so you're
talking about almost 50 percent I'm all
Bitcoin ever created haven't moved into
year right pretty compelling that's I
think we're at 18 million have been
mined so you know you get lost stolen
what in or destroyed whatever in there
the floats really not that big if you
think about it yeah wait what is it well
you got the strong hands that aren't
selling you got the million or so that's
you know Satoshi's right that's not
moving yep yeah you know I think
estimates are like 10 percent maybe up
to 15 percent the keys are lost you know
so the studies I've seen there's
probably the floats around 6 million
Bitcoin out of the 18 million they
actually trades so you know that's
really not that much yeah it's crazy man
this is a to me I just think back and I
say you know 20 years from now when
people look back at this thing mm-hmm
they're either gonna be like these were
the biggest idiots in the world right
like look at all these millions of
people who are idiots or they're gonna
be like man we missed what's probably
gonna go down as you know one of the
most disruptive things in finance right
you know so being a value investor
people look at me like how can you be a
value investor and be involved in
Bitcoin
and when you look at value you look at
today's value but with BIC when you look
at the future value right what's the
future value and so there are ways to
determine what the future values on be
so and this was the hardest thing for me
to get my hands on at the very beginning
it took me two years to figure this out
like what will Bitcoin be worth in the
future and there's ways to determine
that so tomley funds track came out with
a great model it's based on Matt Capps
law so if you take you've you square the
number of users multiply that times the
transactional value that's going through
the Bitcoin blockchain between 2014 2017
there was a 94% correlation to that
model and the price of Bitcoin and then
from December 2017 to today the R
squared the correlation is only 59% so
it dropped and what happened in December
2017 was the ability to short Bitcoin
and so what that means to me is that
someone has their thumb on the price of
Bitcoin today keeping the price down
because of the shorts that are out there
that regression model says that the fair
price of Bitcoin today is 51 thousand
dollars and that's at eight thousand so
if those shorts close out then I would
think that Bitcoin will leave do you
want that okay so this is important it's
one of the things that when people say
to me you know what's happened before
it's gonna happen again kind of really
server Peter yourself one of the big
changes that makes me think and kind of
pause for a second is the shorts right
the ability for the derivatives and ago
shorts that show what stops there being
persistent short pressure I think there
will be a short pressure but they won't
be as strong yeah I think logs are much
stronger than the shorts right now no
yeah
today the Long's are stronger than
shorts but I think the shorts will
eventually panic once Bitcoin hits an
all-time high again because then the one
it closed out because then it's pretty
now trips it's breaking out to new highs
and when it once it hits 20 then it's at
50 like in a very short time period yeah
so and
to me it's you know when you look at the
short pressures really not that much but
it's there that's not right and so it's
interesting to see yeah I go to look at
the stock two flows to Metcalfe's law
you know all these different things that
to me is the big thing is when you get
this having you know what happens and
right those models break or not because
of the introduction of the shorter yeah
the stock to flow model is another great
one ninety five percent correlation
crazy you know so that's a good one
there's a Bitcoin to gold one two it has
a ninety nine percent correlation really
so in 2012
it took one tenth of an ounce of gold to
buy one Bitcoin okay today it takes six
ounces of gold to buy a Bitcoin and what
that model says with a ninety nine
percent correlation is that after the
next having it's going take about eighty
five ounces of gold to buy one Bitcoin
really and that has a ninety nine
percent how do they determine that it's
a formula that yeah I I'm not smart
enough to come up with a formula yeah
but I have it so got it yeah
alright so you guys have also invested
in bankruptcy claims maybe tell us a
little bit about kind of that strategy
how you came across and how that works
okay so like I said the fund was you
know 80% liquidated in December 2017
kind of sat there is a shell with my
money and my son had a little bit money
in it yeah it was we didn't do anything
at all last summer I discovered some
opportunities and bankruptcy proceedings
that allow us to get access to Bitcoin
for almost free okay so the way the
claim works is that there's this
custodian that had Bitcoin they went
bankrupt
each claim comes with about seven
hundred and eighty four dollars of cash
and then point one five Bitcoin and
point one five Bitcoin cash so if I if I
had one Bitcoin on this with this
custodian for every one Bitcoin I had I
now am owed seven hundred eighty four
dollars in cash right plus one point one
five Bitcoin point one five Bitcoin
that's right okay so it's about two
thousand dollars in value and I have a
claim yeah but it's like yeah it's
saying I will get this in the future at
some point when
trusty when the bankruptcy trustee
distributes the assets that's what
you're in get okay okay so and the
question is when will that happen and
that's I happen sometime the next one to
three years probably so we're buying
those claims you know from people who
need to sell them because they have life
events you know they are getting married
or having a baby or need a house or they
wrecked the car they need a car so
they're like for sellers so we're
bidding on this fortress bids on these
you know we're we pay anywhere from $700
to $900 a claim and so we're getting
like two thousand dollars of value and
that's a win so when these claims get
paid out we're paying let's say eight
hundred dollars and we're getting seven
hundred and eighty four dollars of cash
we're getting the Bitcoin and Bitcoin
cash for almost free and so there's
those those type of value investments
that we're making an off the chain
capital yeah in something like that
what's the risk right so so it's great
you put out seven hundred nine hundred
bucks you get a piece of paper says
you're owed you know seven hundred
eighty four dollars in cash and bring
some some Bitcoin Bitcoin cash what's
the downside there's a out yeah there's
a couple downside so one um there's one
lawsuit that still needs to be settled
to coin lamps and if that gets you know
paid out then you know you know that's
probably another it so reduce the cash
by sixty two dollars so I mean we may
not get 780 for it so I mean something
less than that another risk is that if
Bitcoin goes up a lot and the trustee
decides to sell the Bitcoin and it goes
up further then we're stuck with cash
and set a Bitcoin so there's some you
know upside camp potential the trustees
said they're not going to sell any more
Bitcoin so yeah but you know there's no
guarantee that they won't yeah how how
does the trustee in these bankruptcy
type situations know when to liquidate
or disperse yeah like what's the is it
just once ever all of the lawsuits are
separate yeah there's one more lawsuit
that's done once that's done then
they're free - yes tribute mm-hmm
interesting what are their value a
percentage you see in the market so
another thing that we do is we provide a
look quit
Poole for employees up watching
companies so you know there are number
of blockchain companies that are three
to five years old now you have employees
that work there ninety nine percent of
their net worth is tied up in their
company stock right and you know and
they have life events you know that
they're like you said married divorced
babies need a new home wrecked a car you
know whatever it is and so the they need
liquidity to help you know diversify the
portfolio but also just pay expenses and
so you know we provide you know
liquidity pool we offer you know to buy
stock from employees at these companies
and we generally get like a 20 to 30
percent discount from the last round
they because of the illiquid investment
and so and so that's another thing that
we do we buy you know stock from
employees of these companies got it and
how do they find you like in terms of
through the network so I've been in the
space for six years now through the
relationship at poly chain and digital
currency group and just my network yeah
so that's how we we people know you're
willing to buy we're willing to buy yeah
so any blocked any employees up watching
companies out there if you have a life
event you need to have some liquidity
let us know yeah and it's funny too
because when you're known as bullish
around something naturally those
opportunities are attracted to you right
people start to realize hey you know
there's somebody talking about X I think
that this person can help and they kind
of run over their self right it's all a
relationship yeah it's a relationship
business for sure what in the last six
years what's the biggest things that
have changed in the industry
well when Bitcoin first started people
thought it was gonna be like a cash
payment system right and that use case
totally failed you know it's you think
it failed or we just haven't had enough
time for why I think there'll be a cash
settlement system on top of Bitcoin okay
so a layer 3 layer yeah I don't think
Bitcoin will be well I don't think we'll
use Bitcoin you know for a cash system
because you know if you're not if you're
the block size is one megabyte you can't
use it as a you know there has to be
something built on top of that that will
interact with the Bitcoin blockchain so
I
we don't know what that is yet you know
and you know maybe Lightning Network or
Libra or whatever you you know even like
venmo
you know venmo has the opportunity to
interact with the you know Bitcoin
blockchain in the future so I think
they'll do it well once Isis on the
board a PayPal and PayPal Owens been my
house oh right I mean I don't think it's
out of the question yeah yeah he you
think he'll ever get credit for kind of
all the work he did what do you mean
when sis just in terms of like he really
seeded Silicon Valley with hey this
thing's real right just the
conversations and the people he
eventually convinced etc yeah and to me
he's like one of the folks in the
industry who just has never really kind
of broken outside of the crypto industry
right if you think about well there's
the winklevosses you know Brian arms try
there's a lot of people who I think are
known as having done certain work to
kind of push this forward but once this
to me is still kind of insulated inside
of the crypto industry and so it's
interesting he sits on the PayPal board
right you know like it's not just a
crypto only thing for him but but I
don't know he just seems like he's in a
different place than most conversations
yeah yeah I agree with that yeah yeah so
I mean he's a great leader for the space
mm-hmm so we'll see what's next for you
guys like what else are you guys looking
at her excited about yeah so we're just
building you know we're out you know
fundraising you know meeting with people
and just trying to get people involved
mm-hmm so are there any investment
opportunities you guys looked at over
the last couple of years that initially
you're like wow this is amazing
and then as you dug deeper into it
you're like well hold on a second that
was you know shiny on the outside but I
see those all the time all right well
yeah like maybe don't name one of them
but can you change how I like why I
would like when you dug into it what was
the the issues yeah just a revolves
around trust okay yeah so you know you
talk to people and they have this great
idea they're building this protocol and
you get deeper into it and you figure it
you know you see it's leveraged up to
one hundred to one or the business model
which is too risky
or you know there's just you know you
find out that you know there's just not
they tell you one thing and you find out
something different you know so yeah you
know in like I said earlier this is a
relationship business and you can't
trust the people you're working with and
I just I don't deal with that so yeah I
just kind of walk away you sound like a
real venture capitalist now I'm still
trying to figure that job out you know I
think you're doing just fine
what uh what speaking of that before you
in rapid-fire questions what's the one
thing that you know now that you would
never have guessed when you first
started do more of like the venture
capital in stock brokerage like a big
your big lesson learned over the last
six years uh there was like the venture
investing an adventure what I know now
yeah just like what was the biggest
surprise or the biggest lesson you
learned that you didn't expect I think
it was from the partner at 8:16 Z that
she said just buy Bitcoin yeah I mean I
should have just put all my money in
Bitcoin you know instead of doing any of
the VC stuff your life would be simple
and you know like much easier like yeah
I do I have to deal with the companies
and then yeah she was right yeah I mean
she's the 100% right all right you've
been around for six years so these
rapid-fire should be good most important
company in crypto so I like to look at
past and future okay okay so past
definitely coinbase okay just because
they've helped give people access to you
know kyc AML access to crypto you know
in a legal format that allows in the
u.s. in the u.s. that allow people to
own it you know and and they did it the
right way you know they did you know by
following the rules and you know doing
it you know doing a great job doing that
looking forward I think backed has the
potential that they're gonna be in you
know one of the top companies in the
space why from what I know from what
they're building today
that you know I think it's not give
people the ability to have even more
access through traditional financial
means you know because you know our
financial systems but with brokerage
firms and you know just the traditional
finance so things that we've built over
last 50 60 years and that with backed
being you know FinCEN regulated Fenner a
regulated SEC regulated I think that's
why I give the traditional finance
people the ability to get exposure to
this space with someone they're
comfortable with a you know that's owned
by then or kinda like change okay what's
the one rule or regulation you would
change if you could definitely the
credit investor rule yeah I mean can we
just call it a dumb rule yeah so I met
with J Clayton two years ago a digit so
was that like so it's kind of a funny
story or smiling alright so so I get
this call out of the blue from the SEC
saying J Clayton is zombie in st. Louis
I'm at the Federal Reserve Bank and he's
looking he just got hired by Trump and
he's looking to you know he's on this
educational tour and they asked me to
come meet with him and I was like how'd
they find out like like why would you
contact me like how do you know who I am
and they're you know I didn't ask that I
was like yeah sure and you know it
sounds like a privilege I'll go meet
with them and so I'm heading down to the
Federal Reserve Bank in st. Louis and
that's her thinking like like I sorta
freaking myself out a little bit like
like I'm in crypto I know I'm going to
the Fed yeah unreal jaitley SEC I
started getting nervous you know and I
get down there and I'm kind of like you
know jittery a little bit and I walk in
and there's two security guards and they
asked for my wallet and my car keys and
I was like oh that's kind of an yeah I
was like weird you know so I give my
wallet my car keys and they walked
behind a door or like another wall and
and this lady comes up to me and she
goes are you Brian Estes and I look at
her and I was like who's asking yeah
like like why are you asking like I was
like I'm like who are you and why are
you asking me that
and
she goes our kids went to a great school
together I'm Lisa and I'm like like oh
yeah Lisa you know we started talking
don't do that to me right now Lisa and
then the guards came back and they had
just scanned my wallet and my car keys
you know and then they gave back to me
and then they escorted me up to meet
with J Clayton and there are a few other
people up there too
to meet with them and like I said he was
just on information over to her and so I
met with them and thanks JC oh [ __ ] yeah
so so he was asking what can we do at
the sec to make us you know better and
that's one thing I pointed out to them I
go it's not fair to have the SEC
restrict people from investing and
private companies you know if you don't
have a certain net worth or a certain
income I go it makes much more sense to
base it on knowledge I go one degree I
set up a website where people could take
a test or get educated and then if they
pass that test then they could be
accredited and you know you know it's
not that hard as two years ago and he
but to their credit I think that they
are trying to move in that direction
they're slow right but they're big
organization they got a lot of risk
lawyers whatever right yeah heretic but
I do think that they're trying to move
in that direction it's just I think most
people wish it was a little bit faster
yeah but I think that's the one thing
that needs to be done yeah your it
should be your knowledge that determines
whether or not you're accredited how big
your bank account us what so the most
controversial thought you haven't crypto
like what do you what do you believe in
everyone else disagrees with you on I
don't like talking about this but you
keep on a podcast so I think bitcoins
almost like a black hole if I suck in so
much value that we can't really imagine
how high it's on go I agree with that
yeah I just I don't think we could
imagine I I look back at people that
were mining Bitcoin who knows that like
a nickel and tons on some 8000 day they
could never imagine be 8,000 right yeah
and I think in 20 years or 50 years or
whatever you know 8,000 or it's on a
second so much of value
that you know we're not gonna know where
that so there's two things here I always
think about the Bill Gates quote right
we overestimate what we can do in one
year undressing what we can do right
definitely that happen at that point but
to is if you said to me are we
overhyping or under hyping Bitcoin what
you then have to do is you have to look
at the potential and I think most of us
get too short-sighted in what it could
become
it's really hard to imagine right if you
think about the Internet when it first
started even ten years in nobody could
imagine today walking around this cell
phone you know which I don't use to make
very many calls it's write supercomputer
my pocket
right and so if you think about that if
you look at computing power right
there's a photo when my partner's
tweeted that I think it's a gonna I be M
mainframe that today could hold like six
photos you know in today's world but
they're pushing it into like an
18-wheeler right like a literally pretty
game frame into this big truck today you
have more computing power in your pocket
right and it's only you know what maybe
80 years 90 years later like so long
time right like one one lifetime
basically but still that's incredible so
if you think about something like
Bitcoin if it works right that's a big
question
yeah but if it works and I tend to agree
with you yeah it is it's something that
we can't fathom yeah and if you think
about the basic concept of Bitcoin I
kind of look at it as DNS so you had all
these protocols that were developed in
the early 90s like HTTP and SMTP and and
DNS was one and DNS actually has out he
write the domain name system so back in
the early 90s I remember my friends were
buying domain names and squatting on him
and I was like why are you doing that
you know that seems silly to be you know
25 or 50 bucks for amazon.com or
coca-cola calm and that's when there was
just a few hundred thousand or a million
people using the Internet
but when there were billions of people
using the Internet those domain names
became valuable right there
you know how
valuables the amazon.com domain name
today if Amazon forgot to re-register
their domain name and someone stole that
from him and reread shoot it you know
like what would that be worth what would
enhance on millions so my son actually
did that his high school forgot to
register their domain name and he
registered in his name when he was in
high school nearly 16 what happened to
him yeah no you asked me if he should
sell it back to the school and I was
like yeah if you want to flunk out you
probably should just give it back to him
you know yeah and because what's worth
something like yeah it is worth
something right
of course yes so domain names are kind
of like Bitcoin yeah you know because
it's you know domain DNS is open source
protocol Bitcoin is open source protocol
but as more and more people use bitcoins
since there's a finite supply when
there's you know you know billions of
people use it in the future it's
somebody worth more than it's today of
course so I look at it the Bitcoin and
domain names are DNS all in the same
package yeah what um what's the most
important book you've ever read um most
important I know you've talked about
thinking Grow Rich that really helped me
when I was younger um that book
specifically if you read it in your
early 20s oh yeah that's what is I think
it's a perfect image I read it every
three years
oh really yeah I've read it like you
know yeah ten times I like I yeah I I
mean I asked my kids to read it for my
Christmas present last year yeah we
looked like we had book club yeah yeah
they did it we we read the book together
and and went through chapter by chapter
and talked about it and they're my kids
are in college and they really enjoyed
it I didn't think they would yeah and my
wife read it too for the first time
that's all say and yeah so and I give it
out to people as gifts so yeah so that
that's a great book but the most
important book I've read recently that's
probably the Bitcoin standard yeah I
just waited a two weeks ago great job
with yeah yeah so yeah it's great book
it's one of those books you're reading
like damn I gotta go
yeah I'm not thinking big enough
aliens real I mean the probability is
yes I mean yeah you can't
so there's probability of life form is
100 you know you're nearly hundred
percent the question is is it advanced
you know is it human like you know were
the conscience you think I I think yeah
I mean yeah
did they have pets yeah that's how it
started man
yeah I don't know I mean that's like why
don't think about it right so how many
we would we look at Joe the other day we
saw 8 8 million species in the world and
he on earth there's no stats on how many
of those species have pets let me ask
you something weird question are there
other animals on earth that have pets
there are humans only have pets know
that if they have pets so I'll give you
a couple of examples one is we've
definitely seen things like you know the
kangaroo that puts like some other
animal and pouch and like rolls around
with it right
exciting that is it pretending it that
it's a kid or a pet like our human kids
kids or pets or I hate that's one too is
there's been situations where some big
you know wild life type cat for example
may raise a dog again this kid or a cat
right or a pet and then when I saw
another episode was a friend of mine
said well your dog has pets now your dog
is got toys right but it takes care of
it like a pet right now it's an
inanimate object so like does it have to
be conscious intelligent you know all
stuff so it depends really kind of how
you define the stuff right without
getting to kind of better so I a lien is
have pets well so here's the thing right
if the aliens are advanced because if
it's just you know bacteria and
something like that then you know
whatever but but to me it was more of
it's a question that could really get to
like how advanced how civilized how
sophisticated are they right and again
he goes back to you know we think we're
pretty smart but maybe were the idiots
yeah there was something on the news
what like just a couple days ago about
some radio frequency that yesterday high
frequency radio waves billion miles away
yeah
and or the Navy pilots that you know the
UFOs yeah the UFO those little tic tacs
that they have on video I mean what are
those yeah and look part of it is there
are probably scientific explanations for
let's say all of it right literally
every single thing you and I've ever
thought about that could be alien
related has an explanation mm-hmm
there is still such a big universe out
there probability is you know yeah
the scary part is if they show up here
do we or do we welcome them I mean I
guess everyone's will be scared but I
guess the people usually get invaded
doesn't turn out so good for them Yeah
right
all right well one question here for me
to finish up what are you doing in ten
years ten years so you getting married
right yeah I'm married I I think that
there's one core thing we'll see about
all that I don't know how much I say I
have but in 10 years I think that the
safe kind of common thread through
everything I've ever done is learning
right and whether it was learning from
an operator's perspective from an
investing perspective doing you know
this in terms of I just got to sit and
talk to people all day and learn I think
that that's just like something that I
really gravitate towards and it's
similar to a question I've got a friend
who he asks every single person he meets
he goes if money didn't matter what
would you work on right right and like
some people's answers like materially
change right if you're you know
especially working an hourly wage job
you're like hey look I would give this
up tomorrow if money didn't matter
because I would go do something right
that they feel is more they're
passionate about meaningful whatever
then some people their answer wouldn't
change yeah they say look I do this for
free right or if my t matter I'd spend
all my time doing this I think that for
me learning is it's fascinating to me
right I did an episode recently with a
nuclear engineer who spent 20 years in
the Navy and now he works on these
nuclear power plants I knew nothing
about nuclear power and I walked away
now I'm like
[ __ ] like that's a you know and you go
down this rabbit hole right and so being
able to do that over and over and over
again whether it's in conversations or
it's reading or whatever I think is fun
the hard part is do you do that from
like a professional standpoint that more
of a personal thing you know in what
form does it's a hobby or a job and look
and some of those things might be the
same thing but it's also what form
factor does it take do you just sit
around and just read books all day right
like yeah maybe or do you you know take
that learning and apply it somehow I
don't know but I think that's just like
the the easy answer to me is something
around learning new things is exciting
what would you do ten years ten years
from now
yeah probably play video against my
grandkids we never let allowed our kids
to have video games in the house but
yeah the grandkids are different story
all right well listen thank you so much
for for coming and doing this you've got
some some amazing stories and I thank
you having me I appreciate it yeah I
think more people should should know you
and and hopefully some good stuff comes
out of this I want do it again in the
future sounds great thanks